thank you for joining us today first  thing this morning  i want to send all the love and support  to chrissy teigen and john legend  at last night chrissy shared  uh that she lost her pregnancy and i  cannot imagine the pain and i personally  know  so many people who have gone through  this and  by being so open and sharing this they  are going to be helping  so many people feel so much less alone  this openness this gesture  this privilege that you have brought us  into this experience with you  chrissy and john we are so sorry  and i hope that we can all collectively  show  our appreciation for your family  and um chrissy said in her post  that every day can't always be sunshine  but maybe we can provide you with a  little light  in honor of your family  [Applause]  [Music]  you